Ось, до речі, яскравий приклад імітації охорони заказнику.
Просто шикарний!
Олег Вяткін ось уже багато років веде запеклу боротьбу
з чиновниками всіх рівнів, вимагаючи, звадалося б,
елементарного виконання природоохоронного законодавства.
31-й еколог викриває факти варварського видобутку чорнозему,
торфу, бурштину, піску, крейди
на заповідних територіях України.
Як ось у цьому глухому селі на Харківщині.
Колись це було крейдовою горою, на якій росли
рідкісні рослини з Червоної книги.
Перемога буде остаточною, коли оштрафують тих, хто знищив цей заказник.
Голова сільради, як мінімум, зрозумів,
що заказник треба охороняти.
Захист української природи для Олега не пусті слова –
він живе цим. З дитинства мріяв працювати біологом і досліджувати
загадковий світ тварин та рослин.
Та вже на першому курсі біофаку зрозумів,
що поки не час наукових досліджень.
Уже студентом почав допомагати єгерям боротися з браконьєрами.
Молоді,дурнібули…
Лізли між загонщиками та мисливцями.
В наш бік навіть стріляли…
Тоді це перетворилося в справжню партизанську війну.
Вяткіна бояться в багатьох заказниках, заповідниках та національних парках України.
Він не відстане від чиновників, допоки ті
не відреагують на екологічні злочини.
Саме йому та його колегам з «Печеніг» вдалося відстояти
один з великих національних парків України «Дворічанський» -
результат трьох років боротьби,
щоб заповідні землі не виводили з-під охорони держави.
Якщо уявити, що завтра сюди приїде екскаватор і почне тут усе руйнувати…
гадаю, будь-яка адекватна людина, побачивши це,
як мінімум, обуриться.
Так вийшло, що я можу щось зробити. От і роблю….
Олег не розуміє, як люди можуть залишатися
байдужими до знищення природи.
Як ось оцих реліктових дібров по всій країні.
Адже разом з дубами зникають цілі види рослин та комах.
Двісті років йому точно.
Це, як раз, заради таких реліктових дубів
і створювався донецький нацпарк «Святі гори».
Більшість кампаній на захист довкілля – це альтруїзм екологів-"печенігів",
лише зрідка вдається вибороти якийсь міжнародний грант.
Тож, Олег іронічно називає себе з однодумцями «безсрібляниками».
Утім, інакше свого життя вже не уявляє.
Піти в політику, аби через Верховну Раду захищати довкілля, не хоче.
Вважає, що на своєму місці
робить значно більше.
Ось у цих самих пеньках і є різниця
між нашимі здоровим європейським суспільством…
Якби суспільство, яке могло б припинити цю рубку,
було б консолідованим,
цієї рубки не сталася б.
На відміну від Європи,
де політики по-справжньому переймаються захистом довкілля,
в Україні чиновники здебільшого бачать в природі
джерело свого збагачення.
Олег сподівається, що рано чи пізно це зміниться.
І що він, "лицар довкілля", як його іноді називають у Харкові,
цьому сприятиме. Бодай заради майбутніх поколінь.